[Applaus]
[Musik]
die region roger war im norden syriens
land zwischen euphrat und tigris seit
alten zeiten kornkammer des mittleren
ostens
hier leben schon immer kurden gemeinsam
mit arabischen stämmen ethnischen und
religiösen minderheiten getrennt durch
von europäischen mächten willkürlich
gezogene grenzen
auf der anderen seite der mauer die
türkei
sie droht mit einem militärischen
einmarsch den sie weiter westlich in
afrika schon wahr gemacht hat nach dem
zerfall des osmanischen reichs wurden
die kurden gezwungen in vier
verschiedenen staaten zu leben
türkei syrien irak und iran dem traum
von einer eigenen nation wurde ein
gewaltsames ende gesetzt
es folgten jahrzehnte der unterdrückung
durch das autoritäre syrische regime
[Musik]
und darin erkennt
[Applaus]
im zuge des bürgerkrieges übernahmen die
kurden 2012 die mehrheitlich von ihnen
bewohnten gebiete weitgehend kampflos
seitdem ist es den syrisch
demokratischen streitkräften unter dem
kommando der kurden gelungen die region
vom islamistischen terror zu befreien
heute leben zusätzlich über eine
millionen binnenflüchtlinge aus ganz
syrien rosa war
wie einst mark
irgendwie die soße
[Musik]
unter führung der kurdischen partei pd
begann gemeinsam mit den minderheiten
für rosa war ein neues gesellschafts
projekt der aufbau einer
basisdemokratischen selbstverwaltung
damit verzichten die kurven auf einen
eigenen staat
ziel ist eine autonome region innerhalb
eines föderalen staates syrien aber auch
das syrische regime bedroht die
autonomie rosa was
[Musik]
[Applaus]
überall ist ein enormer aufbau wille
spürbar
für die entfaltung der zivilen und
wirtschaftlichen strukturen spielt die
beteiligung der frauen eine zentrale
rolle
kern ist die lokale selbstorganisation
hier gibt es eine verfassungs nimmt sich
der gesellschafter fahrt von sosa war
und das ist sozusagen das theoretische
konzeptionelle und fiktive ideellem rest
des ganzen aber auch die zielsetzung und
www die gesellschaft soll organisiert
seien auf grundlage von kommunen das ist
die unterste wichtigste ebene die sich
ganz eng stadtteil räten
zusammenschließen und diese stadtteile
redet dann sich dann in einem stadtrat
zusammensetzen und beraten in einer
region oder kanton und kanten eine
gesamte region
[Musik]
was kann ich für sie tun
ich brauche hilfe
wir sind als flüchtlinge hier in der
mode und bekommen keine hilfspakete in
der nachbarschaft die nächste
hilfslieferung kommt erst in 15 tagen
hast du anspruch darauf
hast du das familienbuch mit ohne das
habe ich auch nichts bekommen
ich suche nach dem familienbuch du musst
es mir geben dann kann ich einen antrag
stellen und die nummer des familien
buchs ist doch die gleiche wie in meinem
ausweis ohne das familienbuch können wir
dir nicht helfen
es tut mir leid das ist die
voraussetzung für die organisation der
hilfe durch die uno sie muss in das
familienbuch gestempelt werden bei der
nächsten lieferung bist du dran aber
bringt das familienbuch mit wenn du
kommst
ich habe zwei söhne im militärdienst und
bin allein mit meinem kleinen sohn
uns geht es allen genauso mein sohn
kämpft auch aber ihr müsst zwischen
hilfsbedürftigen flüchtlingen und den
einheimischen hier unterscheiden
alle unsere kinder sind an der front ich
könnte jetzt viel mehr erzählen
mein sohn ist auch an der front und ich
habe bisher kein hilfspaket bekommen
manche klopfen bei denen von der
selbstverwaltung an und die helfen dann
zuerst ihren verwandten und freunden
nein alle bekommen hilfe der reihe nach
außerdem hängt es vom umfang der
lieferungen ab wir sind seit drei
monaten hier
vor drei monaten habe ich mich schon bei
euch angemeldet seit wann bist du hier
aktiv
seit fünf jahren bin ich im stadtteil ab
aber schon seit 20 jahren sympathisantin
wie ist es gelaufen in den fünf jahren
gut
am anfang gab es schwierigkeiten für uns
und die bevölkerung aber jetzt ist es
besser geworden
wir haben den menschen die idee der
lokalen selbstverwaltung vermitteln
können
die bürger wissen was wir machen und wir
wissen über ihre lage bescheid welche
probleme sie haben und was sie leiden
wir arbeiten hier nicht für unseren
privaten nutzen sondern es geht uns um
die lage jeder einzelnen familie
wir gingen die haushalte und fragen nach
ihrer situation inzwischen wissen wir
worunter sie leiden oder welches
medikament sie benötigen
es geht um die idee dass die
gesellschaftliche demokratisierung auf
der einen und die gleichstellung der
frauen auf der anderen seite einen
voneinander abhängiger prozess ist die
gleichstellung darf dabei nicht nur
ideell oder formal bleiben
sie muss sich praktisch werden in dem
die frauen in allen wichtigen
gesellschaftlichen sphären
vertreten sind alle öffentlichen
positionen werden dabei paritätisch mit
einem mann und einer frau besetzt
die rechte der freunde sind verloren
gegangen und die frauen werden
unterdrückt die probleme unter denen sie
leiden haben nicht zum nachdenken
gebracht das war der grund für mich
hiermit zu machen damit ich frauen
unterstützen kann
es gibt sehr viele hilfesuchende oft
noch kinder und naiv die sehr leiden
ihre eltern denken wie in alten zeiten
einige werden als minderjährige
verheiratet obwohl sie körperlich noch
nicht so weit sind
ich möchte helfen dass es den jungen
frauen besser ergeht
unsere frauen die kurdischen frauen im
allgemeinen sind noch teilweise
unterdrückt ich sage nicht gänzlich
unterdrückt sondern zur hälfte wie sind
sie unterdrückt die frau ist ökonomisch
und finanziell von ihrem mann abhängig
ein haushalt mit vier bis fünf personen
wird nur von einer person versorgt und
das reicht oft nicht aus
das sind die schwerwiegendsten probleme
mit denen hier hier konfrontiert zeit
manche männer schlagen und demütigen
ihre frauen das wollen wir beenden
vor ein paar wochen kam eine frau die
von ihrem mann geschlagen wurde
ihr gesicht war ganz blau wir haben uns
lange bemüht ist wir das problem lösen
konnten
es gibt jetzt bei uns ein neues gesetz
das die polygamie verbietet darüber bin
ich sehr froh
nicht weil ich angst habe dass mein mann
eine zweite frau ins haus bringt nein
und das ist so ein bisschen die größte
herausforderung und chance dass das
element was das am meisten eng wie zu
bearbeiten
er verlangt und die größten reibung
versucht aber gleichzeitig die fläche an
der man sich nach vorne bewegen kann
wie siehst du die frau heute das ist
nicht mein interesse
nein im ernst völlig frei und sprechen
sie mal das tv heute frei ist
im allgemeinen sind dass sie mündig
geworden und im öffentlichen raum aktiv
ist
davon profitieren wir alle als ich um
die hand seiner tante angehalten habe
traute ich mich nicht sie anzuschauen
und sie traute sich nicht den männern t
zu bringen
aber für die jungen und mädchen heute
ist es viel entspannter zu unserer zeit
haben die väter über ihre töchter
bestimmen zum beispiel meine heirat oder
die deines vaters ohne väterliches
einverständnis ging gar nichts heute
entscheiden die jungen leute selbst
natürlich beraten sie sich noch mit
ihren vätern das gehört sich so
aber in einem akzeptablen rahmen und das
ist sehr gut so sagte auch der islam
du sollst nach seinem wunsch und freien
willen
doch unsere väter haben dies durch ihre
gesellschaftlichen regeln und
traditionen ins negative verkehrt
[Musik]
seit beginn der revolution sind wir
dabei und haben viel erlebt sowohl
schwieriges als auch positives wir haben
auch die kraft und die organisation der
frauen innerhalb dieser bewegung kennen
gelernt mit fortschritten wie mit
rückschritten gott sei dank es hat sich
vieles verbessert und zunehmend positiv
entwickelt ich bin seit drei jahren
aktiv und repräsentiere die frauen
kommunen
wir arbeiten viel ich spreche nicht nur
für mich sondern viele aktive in den
kommunen sehen es ähnlich wir machen
sehr viel für die gesellschaft arbeiten
viel und strengen uns sehr an
wir vernachlässigen dabei zum beispiel
die hausarbeit oder unsere kinder und
familien
wir gehen in die kommunen und erledigen
die dortigen aufgaben nimmt viel an
politischen aktivitäten teil
unsere kritik an den verantwortlichen
der höheren ebenen
obwohl wir von allen ebenen der
selbstverwaltung die größte last tragen
die meiste arbeit erledigen wird unser
einsatz nicht entlohnt
aber obwohl wir ohne
aufwandsentschädigung so viel arbeiten
habe ich persönlich einen nutzen davon
gehabt
ich habe meinen horizont und mein
bewusstsein erweitert in intellektueller
und moralischer hinsicht in der kommune
arbeit habe ich viel mit anderen
menschen zu tun und die gesellschaft
besser kennenlernen können
im politischen bereich habe ich jetzt
mehr erfahrung
ich kann meine und die lage in rosa war
besser einschätzen
ich kann zwischen freund und feind
unterscheiden und ja es macht spaß wenn
man gesellschaftlich aktiv ist und sich
persönlich entwickelt ich wurde mir
meines eigenen wertes bewusst habe mich
weitergebildet und viele soziale
beziehungen und freundschaften geknüpft
das gefällt mir an der bewegung
besonders doch wir kritisieren dass es
kein lohn gibt wenn es keinen lohn gibt
werden die kommunen scheitern
und wenn die kommunen scheitern dann
werden auch die räte und die ganze
selbstverwaltung scheitern
die kommunen sind das fundament
sie erledigen die alltäglichen aufgaben
der nachbarschaft und des viertels wenn
diese basisarbeit nicht gelingt dann
scheitern die menschen an die nächst
höheren verwaltungsebenen dort kennen
sie niemanden
[Musik]
unsere arbeit in der kommune ist an
erster stelle organisation und
verwaltung
wir leisten viel für unsere bürger
überall wo wir helfen können zum
beispiel im logistischen bereich
wir arbeiten ab 8 uhr morgens in der
kommune wenn die menschen etwas brauchen
sind wir da ob gasöl hilfsgüter wir
verteilen sie oder kümmern uns um
dokumente in den ersten beiden jahren
hatten wir schwierigkeiten die menschen
verspotteten die kommunen aber in den
letzten drei jahren haben sie verstanden
dass wir für sie da sind
es geht nicht um mich persönlich es geht
um ein gemeinschaftliches system und die
leute wissen bescheid wenn sie ein
dokument brauchen dann kommen sie in die
kommune jemand brauchte dringend wir
haben es zügig organisiert wenn sie
winterhilfe erhalten wollen müssen sie
sich an die kommune wenden
die menschen sind sehr zufrieden wie die
dinge organisiert sind
gestern zum beispiel habe ich mich mit
einem sehr schwierigen humanitären fall
beschäftigt ich habe ihn weitergeleitet
und seine medizinische behandlung zu
ermöglichen
das alles kostet kraft aber wir müssen
es für unser volk machen da wo die
menschen hinkommen sind wir verpflichtet
ihnen zu diensten zu stehen
wir müssen ihnen helfen so gut es geht
denn wir vergleichen uns mit infront
kämpfern
es ist in ordnung wenn wir uns auch
anstrengen müssen denn wir müssen unsere
gesellschaft organisieren
die leute vertrauen jetzt dem system der
kommunen
ich glaube dass wir es innerhalb der
nächsten zwei jahre schaffen werden uns
wirklich autonom zu verwalten
die menschen werden sich selbst
verwalten
[Musik]
die vorteile und nachteile der neuen
selbstverwaltung
man sollte ehrlich und gewissenhaft sein
wenn man spricht nicht übertreiben und
fair sein
die guten dinge in rosa war zuallererst
ist dazu nennen das die region vor dem
chaos und der herrschaft der islamisten
geschützt wurde
stabilität und eine gewisse freiheit
haben sie in der region realisieren
können
durch eine kluge politik sowohl im
inneren als auch mit den äußeren kräften
konnte verhindert werden dass unsere
region zerstört wird
das alles wird die geschichte der
bewegung zugute schreiben die defizite
das ist die andere seite weil die man
auch lange sprechen kann
ich bin nicht in der selbstverwaltung
und bewegung aktiv aber ich kann auf
basis meiner beobachtungen sagen dass
die aspekte wie nur sicherheit und
stabilität die für die menschen am
wichtigsten sind die defizite überwiegen
sicher gibt es defizite ob man will oder
nicht
es ist eine neue erfahrung
die krise hält an die ressourcen sind
knapp es fehlt an expertise der aktiven
und viele positionen sind fehlbesetzt
es wird hier auch viel getratscht und
böses behauptet zerstören
[Musik]
ich habe bei der wahl zur leitung der
commander kandidiert und bekam 590
ständig ich hatte in armut die meisten
stimmen
ein richtiger arbeit in der kommune
besteht im ausstellung von dokumenten
ob es um die leeren einer klärgrube die
reparatur der abwasserleitungen oder um
eine beschäftigung gilt all das musst du
in der kommune beantragen ohne sie
kommst du nicht weiter um in einer
öffentlichen institution einen job zu
bekommen muss jeder bürger zu der für
ihn zuständigen kommune gehen um die
nötigen dokumente zu erhalten
all das wird über das kühlsystem
organisiert
[Musik]
wenn man von direkter demokratie spricht
die an der basis bei den menschen
anfängt und gleichzeitig gibt es ein
zentrum eine zentrale kraft die
entscheidet dann ist das ein großer
widerspruch in alltagsleben stellen wir
fest diese basisdemokratie auf der einen
seite und der zentralismus auf der
anderen das passt nicht zusammen wenn es
denn so ist also wie ich das verstehe
muss die gesellschaft sich selbst
verwalten in jeder hinsicht
ob verwaltungstechnisch sozial oder
ökonomisch das zentralistische steht dem
entgegen
damit die basisdemokratie funktioniert
müssen dafür die räume und möglichkeiten
geschaffen werden
raum für vielfalt und andere positionen
in dem jeder mit seiner identität und
besonderheit das recht hat zusammen mit
anderen das gesellschaftspolitische
geschehen mitzugestalten
auf diese weise wird die basisdemokratie
realisiert und der widerspruch gelöst
auch auf der ebene sehr widersprüchlich
und die elektrisch gehandelt zum
beispiel gibt es 46 kapitalistischer
elemente gewässers normale handel sitzen
also geschäft die sich gegen es werden
waren vertraut andererseits von der
regionalen verwaltung explizit ein wenig
kontrolliert zu sehr waren sie waren ein
und ausbau nach außen wird kontrolliert
es gibt so auch planwirtschaft sich die
elemente ist uns eine grosse absicht und
förderungen eine kooperative wirtschaft
als grundlage zu nehmen
aber ja wissen also eine balance
zwischen verschiedenen denen mit dem
ziel aber letztendlich eine selbst
organisierung stellt verwaltung und
selbstversorgung der ökonomie der
menschen der kommunen der gesellschaft
insgesamt hätten stellen
wir haben unseren laden schönheit der
frau genannt
schöne frau ja schönheit und alles was
die frau braucht wenn sie in den laden
kommt soll sie alles finden was sie
braucht
wir sind hier zehn frauen die sich zu
einer genossenschaft zusammengeschlossen
haben
am anfang hat jede von uns 25.000
syrische lehrer in die genossenschaft
eingezahlt wir hätten auch mit einem
höheren anteil beginnen können
aber diese summe konnte jede von uns
zehn frauen aufbringen
unser zentrales motiv war dass die
frauen aus dem haus kommen
wir sind nicht in erster linie am gewinn
interessiert
die frauen haben zunächst eine gruppe
gegründet und besprochen wie eine
genossenschaft funktioniert es hat sie
überzeugt
nachdem alle frauen ihren anteil
eingezahlt hatten hat der örtliche
frauenrat sie finanziell unterstützt um
den laden einzurichten und die waren
einkaufen zu können
manche der waren hier werden von anderen
frauen hergestellt
zum beispiel mit simon charles alles in
eigenproduktion diese blusen hier
stammen aus einer anderen fabrik die
leute von der fabrik verkaufen uns die
waren und wir verkaufen sie hier auch
noch in anderen farben
[Musik]
es gibt bei uns auch kinderbekleidung
die wird ebenfalls in eigenproduktion
hergestellt
auch in einer kooperative ja in einer
fabrik die als genossenschaft
funktioniert die kooperativen sind alle
miteinander vernetzt
früher hat die frau in der
landwirtschaft gearbeitet und war am bau
der häuser beteiligt wie in vielen
anderen bereichen
daran möchten wir anknüpfen und unsere
materielle unabhängigkeit wieder in die
eigene hand nehmen wenn du nur deinen
mann um geld bittet ist das beleidigend
für dich selbst aber wenn du raus gehst
arbeitest und selbst verdienst egal wie
viel dann bist du selbstständig und
kannst froh sein
wir sind mit unserer arbeit zufrieden
und möchten ein beispiel für die ganze
welt seien nun mit mir in unsere
revolution sind wir frauen an der
kriegsfront im einsatz gewesen
das war genauso wichtig wie unsere
arbeit hier im innern der gesellschaft
das ist auch eine front wir haben beides
zugleich geschafft wir sind stark und
weichen für unseren feinden nicht zurück
wir stehen unsere frau gegen alle
anfeindungen
[Musik]
wir sind die frauen nähwerkstatt in kuba
wir arbeiten hier mit acht frauen und
haben auch eine leitung
wir nähen kleidung für frauen und kinder
für erwachsene und jugendliche die ware
liefern wir nach kuba und in andere orte
wir wollen durch niedrige preise die
gesellschaft unterstützen unser
arbeitsalltag hier ist sehr
geschwisterlich wie in einer familie
wir helfen einander die arbeit ist
wichtig für frauen damit sie
selbstständig sind
anfangs hatte ich schwierigkeiten als
ich hier arbeiten wollte es gehört sich
nicht dass eine frau rausgeht und
arbeitet doch nach und nach durch
freundliche diskussionen und durch
bildung hat sich meine familie
überzeugen lassen
bei frauen und männer gleichgestellt
sein und gemeinsam für die familie
sorgen sollten
und die frau sollte dabei frei sein
[Musik]
wir koordinieren jeden schritt der
arbeit gemeinsam und wir diskutieren
alle anweisungen
jede von uns hat auch ein stimmrecht
wenn alle etwas ablehnen wird es nicht
gemacht
wir sind froh dass wir hier unsere
eigene meinung haben und auch
durchsetzen können wenn ich nach hause
komme sagen die nachbarinnen gut hast du
arbeitest und mit verdienst wenn es für
uns eine chance gibt möchten wir das
auch aber manche haben noch altmodische
vorstellungen sie sagen warum geht sie
arbeiten
das gehört sich nicht die kinder sind
noch klein warum lässt sie sie viele
stunden allein jeder mensch hat seine
eigene meinung
wir möchten mehr chancen für die frauen
dass sie noch viel weiter vorankommen
[Musik]
bei gott unser alltag ist sehr schwer
manchmal gibt es für einen monat arbeit
und dann zwei monate lang keine der
tageslohn als bauarbeiter ist sehr
niedrig manchmal bekommt man nur 3000
syrische lira dafür kann man noch nicht
mal ein hühnchen kaufen
wir sind froh gottseidank wenn wir über
den tag kommen und etwas zu essen haben
wenn nicht sind wir geknickt aber es
geht weiter
das leben im dorf ist sehr viel
einfacher
dort kannst du eigene schafe halten du
musst keinen joghurt kaufen du musst
keine eier kaufen
auch gemüse und kraut nicht du musst
noch nicht einmal fleisch kaufen
hier steht dort alles zur verfügung du
kannst vieles selbst anbauen
in der stadt ist das total anders
was kann man schon in unserem kleinen
hof anbauen
vorher hatten wir einen stall aber dann
kamen beamte und haben ihn geschlossen
ganze nachbarschaft kommt zu mir
sie wissen dass ich kissenbezüge nähe
das maximum das ich täglich schaffe sind
zwölf bezüge davon sechs kleinere die
anzahl die ich herstellen kann hängt
davon ab ob ich strom habe wenn es
keinen strom gibt wie jetzt kann ich
höchstens die hälfte meiner arbeit
schaffen
wir haben eine bestimmte routine was
unseren täglichen arbeitsablauf angeht
ich stehe auf und bereitet das frühstück
vor mein mann geht zu seiner arbeit
außerhalb des hauses
unsere tochter geht zur schule und ich
gehe zur kommune und erfülle dort
möglich nach 13 uhr komme ich zurück
nach hause wenn es strom gibt gehe ich
an die nähmaschine wer nicht bereite ich
die stoffe zum nähen vor
ja wir würden lieber auf dem land leben
aber wir müssen hier leben weil wir kein
eigenes land besitzen
trotzdem kombinieren wir das landleben
mit dem leben in der stadt
wir haben jetzt scharfe obwohl wir in
der stadt leben wir haben hühner und
enten
wir ernähren uns von unseren tieren von
ihrem fleisch und den eiern
unser leben hängt von unserer täglichen
arbeit ab ja ich wiederhole meine
überzeugung lieber auf dem land zu
wohnen
aber wir haben eben kein eigenes lange
die bevölkerung von hude bau zwiebeln an
und die zwiebeln die du hier siehst
werden von der lokalen bevölkerung
produziert manchen von ihnen gehört sehr
viel land und einige haben auf einer
fläche bis zu vier hektar zwiebeln
angebaut
wir kaufen ihre zwiebeln auf und lagern
sie wir verkaufen und exportieren sie in
das kurdische gebiet im irak und nach
aleppo oder damaskus
hallo wie geht's euch also zur kirche ja
ich mache mein geschäft ich verkaufe
grillhähnchen wie ist der job naja ich
bin zufrieden
mal so mal so und ein studio ich habe es
aufgegeben
warum wegen der situation hier in syrien
habe ich mein studium aufgeben krieg
schränkt uns alle ein
er will sich auch ein schreiben aber die
ganzen anmeldungen dokumente und
abschlüsse das ist alles nicht mehr so 1
ich muss mich in kamishli handeln bei
mir war es in armut wir studieren noch
du hast abgebrochen also bitte ich rate
dir höher mit dem studium auf vor
dienstag kein geld - studierst einige
freunde von mir waren schon im letzten
studienjahr aber sie haben studium
trotzdem abgeworfen siehst du das doch
alles nutzlos aber ich habe angst ich
lernen und lernen schreibe und schreib
und vielleicht werde ich am ende wegen
einer kleinigkeit nicht schaffen
studieren ist nutzlos arbeite lieber und
lebt ein leben ich muss ja auch im
wehrdienst leisten hier gibt es sogar
zwei dem für die syrische armee und den
für die kurdischen streitkräfte gott sei
dank habe ich den wert ihn schon gemacht
optimal wäre es wenn du beide wehrdienst
abgehakt ist dann kannst du frei
rumlaufen
da muss so viel bedenken wenn wir nun
arbeiten studieren oder wehrdienst
leisten
unser lebens ganz schön kompliziert
hört ein freund lass das studium sucht
er eine arbeit oder machen laden hof und
gutes alle menschen die hier
zusammenleben sind jetzt gleich
berechtigt das war vorher nicht so
es gab unter uns christen kurden und
arabern einige probleme doch jetzt sind
alle gleichgestellt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
tatsächlich wenn du dir unserer region
vor allem amodu anschafft aber auch
andere städte in nordsyrien sind so die
menschen leben gemeinsam
wir sind untereinander verwandt und sind
ehen miteinander eingegangen haben
soziale und gesellschaftliche
beziehungen wenn eine trauerfeier oder
hochzeit stattfindet dann sieht man alle
sind da wir picknicken gemeinsam singen
und tanzen gemeinsam wie du hier gerade
siehst ich habe zwei gäste sie sind ich
will sie nicht in araber oder kurden
unterscheiden
sie sind außer mode und gehören der
arabischen ethnie an die hier schon
immer lebt wir treffen uns essen und
trinken gemeinsam singen zusammen
[Musik]
juli
denn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
naja
wie sie dieser basisdemokratisch die
selbstverwaltung wie so gut oder liegt's
ja essentiell von der sätze
organisierung die gesellschaft und wie
sich wie gesagt im nahen osten was über
jahrhunderte jahrzehnte und die
gesellschaft unter zurück war und eine
sitzung sagen eine sehr passive haltung
sozialisierung der menschen die hier
vonstatten gegangen ist wir haben einen
auf der einen seite ein modell oder ein
gesetzes modell der eine aktivität von
menschen voraus setzt auf der anderen
seite haben wir eine region die mit
einer sehr unterdrückten geschichte und
sehr passiven gesicht während das gilt
insbesondere für die frauen
aber man kann das auch anders sehen und
sagen aus unseren gezwungen aufgrund der
erfahrung bestehen sehr viele potenziale
[Musik]
wir haben hier ein 400 quadratmeter
großes grundstück das der nutzbar machen
wollen
wir wollen darauf ein restaurant bei wir
werden alle einrichtungen der
selbstverwaltung mit essen beliefert und
alle arbeitenden menschen die keine zeit
zum kochen haben können bei uns
traditionelles essen aus ermutigen
neeson wird das restaurant auf eine
kooperative sein
ja das wird so sein zehn frauen zwei
köchinnen eine buchführung einige zum
spiel einige zum bedienen und eine
geschäftsführerin
sie alle werden das restaurant gemeinsam
betreiben
der gewinn wird unter allen zehn frauen
aufgeteilt
das wichtigste ziel ist nicht das geld
nein wir müssen alles schön einrichten
natürlich mit internetanschluss und geht
es auch darum die augen zu befriedigen
nicht nur den magen verliebte pärchen
die sich sonst nur auf der straße
treffen können in diesem restaurant
zusammen sitzen
wir haben viele verlobte die ausgehen
möchten aber es gibt kaum auto wo sie in
der öffentlichkeit beieinander sitzen
können beide seiten werden glücklichsein
allen verliebten geht es gleich ganz
egal ob bei euch in deutschland in
europa oder bei uns hier
wir haben auch verliebte die wollen sich
in der öffentlichkeit aufhalten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich schicke meine stimme an all unsere
familien die in die fremde nach europa
gegangen sind
ich kann sagen dass sich unsere
situation hier verbessert ich möchte
dass alle in ihr land zurückkehren bei
unser land sie braucht vor allem in der
jetzigen situation des aufbaus wir
möchten dass möglichst viele unserer
kunden hier leben sehr viele sind
immigriert wir sind zerbrochen weil sie
nicht hier sind
warum sollte europa von ihnen
profitieren irland braucht sie statt
dass sie dort arbeiten sollen sie hier
arbeiten wir wären sehr froh wenn sie
zurückgehen
irland wäre stolz auf sie und ihre
heimat würde sich dank ihrer arbeit
fortentwickeln
[Musik]